Hello, Brian.
Hello, Ketan, how are you?
Doing very well, sir. How are you?
I'm doing good.
Nice, nice, long time.
It's a...
How is everyone at home?
Luckily, well, I'm home today. I'm not sure where everybody else is.
Oh.
It's good.
Um...
Had a pretty easy going day to day, getting some backlog things taken care of, getting the NOC engineers list up to date for all of our access and stuff like that.
Mhm.
Trying to knock out a bunch of low-level crap that just been hanging around for a while, and...
Cool.
That's good.
Cleaning up server disk drives. Yay!
Yeah.
So according to you, what is more productive when you're working from home or when you're working from the office?
Home.
Yeah.
It's less distractions when I'm here. You know, when I'm at the office, there are people that just keep dropping by and interrupting me, ask me to do stuff for them when I'm already in the middle of something. And so when I'm here, there's no distraction.
Okay.
Mm.
unless it's, you know, there's an emergency or something like that. But, you know, the wife leaves me alone and I go take a walk and have lunch with her and that's it. It's a great day. I love working from home. I feel accomplished when I work from home.
Mmm, that's good. It's a good perspective. I believe both the sides have their own pros and cons.
Yeah.
For some who are not used to having...
Beat.
used to being self-sufficient, self-managed, that kind of stuff, to be disciplined.
Mhm.
They should not work from home because they're not going to get anything done.
True.
I've been doing it off and on for, you know, 20 years, so I'm very self-disciplined and get my stuff done as long as I'm just not interrupted.
Yep, yep, yeah, that's what I said. It has its own, you know, pros and cons.
But I think...
One.
Perspective that I have is that when you're working from the office, you interact with so many different individual personalities that you don't get when you're working from home because you're alone, right? So...
Right.
Being a human, you need to get social.
That's why I like my setup right now. It's 2 days in the office and three days at home. I'm sorry, no. Right now I'm three days in the office and two at home.
Mm.
So that's hybrid. I think that's the best model, I believe.
Um...
Yeah, the hybrid model is actually really well because you do get those couple days in the office to interact with different people. So we have everybody coming in on Tuesdays. So everybody that works for TTG other than our remote people are in the office. And then the rest of the week, everybody is a hybrid.
Exactly.
Mhm.
Kour.
Just depends on how many days they're in and out of office.
Mm.
Cool, yeah, I believe you're getting flavor of both the worlds, right? It's a mixture that you're not missing office, you're not missing home. So I believe that's the best setup.
Yeah.
Well, how about Noah? Hey, Noah.
You know?
Hey, sorry, I was, I was at, I was at another meeting.
How are you doing? Is he also working from home?
Yeah, I was working from home, but I was also...
Yeah, is there anyone who's working from the office today or everyone's like working from home and office is like doors are locked?
Look, look, I work from.
No, there's always somebody in the office.
Yeah.
I work from home three days a week, so I only go in there Tuesdays and Wednesdays.
Okay, okay, that's good.
Cool. So are we waiting for Mike to join?
Mike is on a cruise. He's on, he's on boat.
Mike is on vacation.
Ohh.
Wow, he's having the best time of his life, I believe, enjoying cruise with his family.
Look, even if he could join, I don't know if you would want him to join because he may not, he may not be coherent.
No, I would not.
Yeah, that would be too much distraction, right? Because then we all want to be with him enjoying on a cruise. Who minds, right? Anyways, so let's get the show started. I'm going to share my screen and we'll go through the presentation.
Yeah.
Right.
Hey.
I hope my screen is visible.
Yep, I see it.
Oh, awesome. And then we talk about presentations. Brian just left. Maybe he just want to grab a coffee or... Yeah.
He, he doesn't matter.
I'm still here, I'm still listening.
Either it's OK.
Yeah, yeah, we know we know you're listening, just that you're not watching the screen, are you?
Oh, fine. I know you worked so hard on these presentations, Gavin. I got to see your work.
Look.
I'm gonna make Brian see it.
Look, I'm gonna talk to you like I did my kid. Brian, eyes on me. Eyes on me, Brian.
That's so funny, right? That's cool. Eyes on me. That's nice. I learned something new today. I'm going to do it with my kids. Eyes on me. Look.
Look, if if if my kid's not looking at me, I know he's not listening.
Yeah.
Yes.
Great. Okay, so welcome everyone to our monthly business review for TTG. We'll be looking at March month's performance. Agenda item stays pretty much the same. We'll go through the highlights, performance analysis, ITBD CX set, US holiday schedule, team GPS way forward, and then meeting minutes.
Highlights. Manny completed his CompTier A plus Core One training, which he was bragging about on LinkedIn all over social media. I was like, Manny, stop, man. Do the certification, then you can brag all about it. I don't mind. So we'll see if we can get him.
Yeah.
certified because the certification is expensive. So let's see if he's able to get it done. We were also in discussion because from our side we'll reverse it. So let's say it's up to Maddy if he's willing to get it done maybe.
next quarter, but we'll keep you posted.
Yep.
Okay.
Rest on call responsibilities. He is working great on that. I haven't heard anything negative, so I'm happy that he is taking the responsibility and making sure he's not missing all the calls. That's great. I see Vishal joining in. Hey, Vishal, thank you for joining.
Hey, Evan. Hi, Brian, hello. Nice to meet you.
Abe Vishal.
OK, so we just we just started.
Go ahead.
We just started, we just started.
Yeah, please go ahead.
So Brian, Noah, you know Vishal, right? You have connected with him previously. Okay, cool. That's fine. All right, then he created ITBD documents and SOPs. He's been receiving great support from the entire TTT team. Overall, he is in a great position, I would say.
Mmh.
Yep.
to get the work done. Yeah, so that's pretty much the highlights from last month. Anything, Brian, Noah, that you want to add?
Nothing from me. As always, we love Mandy.
Awesome.
Yeah, we actually have given him some extra permissions, really as of this week, really showing how much trust that we have in Mandy to do some of these upper level requests that we're getting in now, instead of having to wait on Noah or myself.
Mhm.
Yes.
You know, we went ahead and promoted.
person in-house and Mandy as far as, you know, what access levels they have in our tools, you know, we've officially made them.
In our minds, what are tier twos, so...
We're really excited to get him in there and start learning a little bit more stuff and taking over some more responsibilities.
Right.
Awesome. That's a, I'm so happy to hear this and I'm sure you know he will be, he's one of those individuals who wants to learn and grow. So with the right coaching, he's going to be a great engineer for all of us, right? And it's great to hear that he's been.
Mhm.
Promoting internally, taking on high-level stuff, so that that's exactly what we were looking for, and then we are happy that he's able to exceed our expectations.
Yeah.
less work during, you know, March month it was light. I think that's why he was able to complete his training because he was getting that time to invest in himself. So that's amazing. Top service requests that are coming in, Kobe users 40%, end user is 35%, monitoring SOC, knock alerts is 15.
Office 365 issues are like 10%. So that's the work that he's been getting. Ticket resolved rate, not a problem for Mandy. It's always about the benchmark score, so that's great. Anything that you want to add to Noah, Mike? Mike, I'm missing Mike. Maybe he's thinking about that. I tell you.
He is, he is me.
Trust me, he's not even, he's not even aware that we exist right now.
Yeah.
Actually, he actually emailed me today. I wanted to yell at him and say, Mike, get off your phone.
MB.
But no, I have nothing. I have nothing to add.
So, he's on the cruise, and...
That's great. So he's on the crews calling you, texting you.
That's good.
Okay, cool. So, yeah, Brian, anything that you want to add?
Nothing for me, just mainly because I don't really interact with the Helpdesk team as much as previous. So this is all good news to me as well. I can understand March. March was kind of slow for a lot of things around here, and even April. That's why we're able to get a lot of things caught up.
Mhm.
But yeah, it's.
Yeah, April's probably going to be about the same as March, to be honest.
Yep.
But it's gonna it's gonna take off here real soon.
Yeah, so I think that's why when I was going through his, you know, board and I did see that spike. So I'm hoping that's going to be more than 70% next month, maybe April month. That's what I'm saying. Okay, cool. So next up we have is CSAT. So thank you so much, Noah, for filling it out for all the months now. So we're back on track.
Right.
Thanks A lot.
I wasn't getting them before and now I started receiving them. After whatever happened with the ticket that was made on my behalf, I'm now receiving them. So I will make sure I fill them out.
Yeah.
Mhm.
That's great.
Thank you, and I'm happy that we were able to fix it because I think Brian did not know, but for November, December, Jan, it was not there. So I was like, Noah, no, you got to fill it out.
Kip.
I remember.
So we are back on track. Thank you. Okay, so moving on, we have the US holiday schedule. He's off tomorrow. Rest, I haven't received any other PD requests. Overall, I think the next one that's coming up is in the month of May, May 25th. We have a month's time, so we will decide. I think from my perspective, you are closed, right? TDG is closed.
Yep.
Correct.
Mhm.
Okay, cool. But if there's any extra days off that he needs, I'll keep you posted.
Lakhwinder.
Kip.
Okay, AI by Design, our next session will be in month of August. So any chance Mike, Noah or Brian, you can make it?
This was something that I know that Mike and Brad had discussed, and I think that they really wanted to try to get to the last one that just happened, but it just didn't pan out. So we'll get this back in front of them and see if they are interested.
Mhm.
Cool, and I believe Andy will keep checking on it so that we can get Mike at least, you know, be part of this event.
Yep.
All right, great. And next up we have...
Team GPS, so we...
We have the QR code on the screen. We have been discussing about it. So if you're interested, do let us know.
Way forward remains the same, Brian, Noah. We just want to make sure that Mandy continues to upskill himself so that he can take on more advanced work and provide you with the value that you're looking for and making sure that his KPIs are being, that the benchmark is being met.
So that's the way forward. As you all know that Mandy has been doing an awesome work, so we just want to make sure that he is consistent in service delivery. Okay.
Yep.
Right, well, that's pretty much it from my side. I'm going to stop sharing my screen. And before we go around the table, there's just one thing from my side.
We are supposed to pay him for March months on call tickets that that he has worked on. So, Noah, you have already approved it. Now, last time.
Mohit.
We build.
Ohh.
I'm so sorry, I forgot his name. Was it Craig, the owner? I mean, I don't remember. Brad, I'm sorry, yeah, Brad, my bad. Thank you, Brad.
Brad.
Brad, Brad.
I'm gonna call him Greg though. I'm gonna say, hey Greg.
Yeah.
Okay, cool. Yeah, so should we follow the same process, like in billing his credit card or anything else that we are supposed to do? Because we have 150 with us and we will pay him, you know, but the idea is to how we should proceed forward because this is a monthly thing.
So do you feel like we should be charging him as per the credit card information that we have, or is there a different process that we should be following?
Mmh.
As far as I know, Brad goes in and manually pays all the ITBD bills on a monthly basis.
Kam.
Yeah, that's when I was talking with Mike about the whole mishap with the billing before. I think it's because Brad went in without looking at it and just paid it manually. So I don't see there being any issue.
So, as long as...
I mean.
Team.
Okay.
Okay, yeah, because from our side, our accounting team will make sure that $200 is reflecting on the portal so that he can get that payment done. Because once the payment is clear, then only we'll be in a position to give Mandy his payout.
Mmh.
Yeah, exactly. Have you sent that over to Brad J or is that coming up?
Okay.
I believe it should be there, but I can double check.
Is that something that Brian will look into it or Brian can you access or I don't know how that is set up.
I have no access to anything. It is all through Brad. Brad is our accounts payable person.
Okay, I think it's gonna be rad.
Okay, understood.
I see that we just received an invoice.
Just this past week for $200.
Mhm.
Yeah, so I think that's what it is then.
Macatol.
So Brad will, Brad will go in and pay ITBD bills usually towards the end of the month.
Yeah, because the...
Mhm.
Okay.
Mm.
So what I'm hearing is that by 30th, it's going to get cleared, right?
Likely.
Well, I can't promise you that. All I can, I'm telling you what I have just sensed how this business works or how this company works. If you want true answers, then yes, you're going to have to go straight to Brad.
Okay.
Understood.
or accounts receivable will have to go straight to Brad.
Under.
Yeah, that makes sense. Kavan, we can just have what, you know, someone from Accounting team reaching out to Brett to just clear that. Anyhow, he's going to do that, so.
Mhm.
Sure.
And please don't let it be Preeti. He does not like emails from Preeti because she is very aggressive.
And he's asked her to back off.
Okay.
Mm.
a lot. So he does go in and pay the bills every month. He just may not get it within that first 15 days because we're waiting on our receivables to come in so then we can pay.
Get that.
Understood. Yep, makes sense. So we just don't want.
So.
I don't know if there's a way that we can change that and just go on some type of net 30 or something like that. But
Mhm.
Yeah, Accounting stuff, that's all Brad. Yeah, I try to stay out of it.
Yeah, in the meantime, if you can just tell him that if you do see like 200 on your side, then you need to approve it because that's for like Maddy's on call. That's the only answer to that.
I will I will actually reforward that email that Kumar sent, Kumar submit, and ask him to pay this immediately.
Mhm.
Awesome. That's what we were looking for. Thank you. Thank you, Brian, for helping us.
But that that will be great, Brian. Actually, you know, we are planning to make this payment to Maddie's account by the end of this month only.
Yu.
That is only until we are trying to have a follow up on this one, but thank you for your help, Brian.
Okay.
Yep, we appreciate it. Thank you, Vishal. So yeah, that's the only action item on my site. Rest, we can go to Noah, Noah, for any questions, concerns, or feedback for us.
Nothing from my side. As always, we appreciate Mandy and everything that he does. We definitely appreciate him with helping with on call. That's taken a lot off of the shoulders of the team because we don't have to worry about being on call for four days, five days straight. So that he's comfortable with being in the on-call rotation. And honestly, I have not seen him
Yep.
a single on-call that came through. We definitely appreciate him taking on the extra responsibility. We know that it was up to him, so he didn't have to do it, but we definitely appreciate him putting in the effort.
Ohh.
doing the same as all the other techs, even if he didn't have to. So no complaints from my side, all positive things.
Perfect. Thank you, Noah. It's music to our ears and we just want to make sure that it continues to not only meet but exceed the expectations.
Oh, of course. And he's definitely exceeding them. I will tell you, it's very, very rare that I get any sort of complaints from any of our clients on anything that Mandy had done. And very rare for him to even ask questions. He does a very good job at going out and finding the answers himself, looking at all the documentation.
using his resources and stuff. So it's definitely all positive from my side.
Perfect, and I'm sure it's going to be the same from Mike as well, but Mike is not here, but we'll go to Brian. Brian.
Yeah.
I'm just going to mimic Noah again. I don't interact as much, but when I do, it's always just a positive experience with Mandy.
Amazing. Thank you.
He he brings a smile to everybody's face.
That's good to hear that. That's great. We wish we could give you 10 more Mandys.
Someday we might need him.
If.
Look, but I will keep you up on that as, hey, we won't accept anything under what Mandy is. If they're not performing and not as happy, not as happy as Mandy, we don't want them.
****.
You're setting, you're setting the bar high.
So that's what I'm saying, that he's raising the bar really high for us now to find.
You know, the technology with clothing is getting high up there right now. Maybe we can just clone Mandy.
You never know. You never know. Yeah, that would be great. Maybe Noah is playing too much of cyberpunk.
Yeah, if luck.
See, I know.
Well, I know what you're talking about, man. I replayed it probably a year ago.
Usually? Oh, that's cool. That's great. Good to know. Okay, so that's pretty much it. Vishal, anything that you want to add?
No, I'm all good. Happy to see Mandy's doing great. Thank you for all the feedback. Anytime if you have any feedback from him where he needs some scope of improvement, I'd just say that don't just wait for this call. Just throw us an email over Teams and we are more than happy to help at any point of time. But I appreciate all your feedback on this one. Thank you so much for your time now.
Thank you so much, Brian.
Thanks, Vishal.
Great, so...
Gentlemen, I'm giving you 8 minutes back. So enjoy yourself, have a good time, and we'll speak to you next month. Till then, take it easy. Bye-bye.
Woohoo!
Thanks, Kobe. Take care.
Back.
Thanks, Evan.